えーと パーリテキストの百三十八ページですね
で これから あの  この実体について
いわゆる魂がですね で
それについてお釈迦様説法
あの テーマ変えるんです
で この前の話で まあお釈迦様おっしゃったのは
この もし変化しない何かあるならば
何かに執着して 何の苦しみも悩みも生まれないならば
そのようなものに執着してもいいんですよと
でも そういうものはあなた方は見つかりますか？と
それはまあ 執着しても良いというものは見つかりませんと
お釈迦様 私もそういうものを見つからないということで
そのポイントで終わっちゃうんですね
だからこの完全にこの執着するのは悪いというではなくて
何か我々に幸せを 安らぎを
永遠な楽しみを 永遠な幸福を与えてくれる変化しない何かあるならば
まあ悪くはないんだけど
そんなものはありますかと
ですから この永遠な命があるにも関わらず
真我があるにも関わらず
梵我があるにも関わらず
そちらに行かないと言ってるわけじゃないんです
もし真我やら梵我やら
あるいはもういろいろ魂
霊魂も天国 なんとかたんでもいいんですけど
この永遠不滅たる究極な幸福になる何か境地
何かものがあるならば
どうぞそちらに執着して頑張ってください
それは悪くはないんだと
ですから まああるにも関わらず
お釈迦様はもうもうすごい残酷に否定しているわけじゃないんですね
お釈迦様たちはそういう永遠不滅の境地
永遠不滅という何か真我
終わりもなき もう消えることもなく
ずっと永遠にある魂 霊魂というものは見つからないんだと
あるんだったらありがたいんだけど
残念ながらないんだよと
というふうな この微妙な論理なんですけど
だからインドで当時でいろいろ永遠な魂というものはね
信仰した宗教の方が多かったんだから
彼らにそんな考え方をやめなさいと
神を捨てなさいと言ったわけじゃないんです
いるならば頑張ってくださいと
神を捨ててくださいと言うんじゃなくて
神がいるならばどうぞ
もうそれはありがたいことで頑張ってくださいと
でも調べてみると 残念なことにいないんですよと
だから頑張ったって もう神と一緒になろうと
一体になろうと頑張ったって
それはただあなた方は苦しむだけですよと
それから今日はそこからなんです
アッ
タニワ・ビッキャヴェー・サティ・アッタニヤン・メーティ・アッサーティー・エーワン・バンテー・アッタニーエー・ワー・ビッキャヴェー・サティ・アッター・メー
ティ・アッサーティー・エーワン・バンテー・アッタニチャ・ビッキャヴェー・アッタニーエーチャ・サッチャトー・テータトー・アヌパラブ・マラーネー・ヤンピダン
・ディッティッターナン・ソー・ローコー・ソー・アッター・ソー・ペッチャ・バヴィッサーニ・ニッチャー・ドゥーオー・サッシャトー・アヴィ・パリナーマ・ダン
モー・サスワティ・サマンタ・テータ・サミーティ・ナーヤン・ビッキャヴェー・ケーワラ・パリポーロー・バラ・ダンモーティ
というところまで説明します
アッタニ・ワー・ビッキャヴェー・サティ
もしアッター・アートマンという大事な何かがあるならば
アッタニヤン・メー 私の我ですよと
私の魂 霊魂ですよという立場が成り立つでしょうと
もしアートマン アットマン
あるいは魂 霊魂があるならば
これが私のアートマンだよ
私の我ですよと 私の霊魂ですよという立場が成り立ちますね
それで比丘たちにそういうことでしょうと聞いたら
比丘たちもそうですよと言うんです
そこで アッタニチャ・ビッキャヴェー・アッタニーエーチャ・サッチャトー・テータトー・アヌパラブ・マラーネー
アッタニ アッタニーエー
いわゆる真我も  本どもの我というものも見つからないし
真我のものという まあ魂に属する魂に関係あるものという何か実際に見つからない場合は
いわゆる真我があって真我のものというのは
これは一般的な宗教で考えればわかりやすいと思います
神がいて神が作った人間がいるという場合は
神は真我で神のものは人間なんですね
だから人間 人類っていうのは神が創造したものだから神のものなんですね
故に我々は真我そのものじゃないんだけど
真我の何か属するものになっちゃうんですね
普通の世の中の宗教ではそういう風に
てるんですね どんな宗教でも
ヒンドゥー教にせとっても
神が梵我がいて 梵我は私っていうことではなくて
梵我が分離して幻想の世界出来上がっちゃったんだから
幻想の世界は我のものなんですね
我から回転して成り立ったものなんですね
キリスト教にしても 神がいて
神が現象の世界を作るんですね
作って それに魂を入れ込む
吹き込む 吹き込んで 世の中は動いているように回転させておくんですね
そこで我々は好き勝手にいろんな回転して
いろんな発展して いろんな発明していっても
結局すべて神のものになっちゃうんですね
最初はものを作って 神が魂を吹き込んで動かしておいたんだから
それでこちら好き勝手に何を開発しようが
結局神のものなんですね
それを西洋のキリスト教の思想になっているんです
ですから アッタにアッタにエという 2つ
お釈迦様はすっごい厳密に哲学的に全ての宗教をまとめて二言葉に取ってみるんですね
アートマンとアートマンに属するもの
魂と魂に属するものって
その 2つ分けてるんです
だからお釈迦様のこの鋭い知恵っていうのはすごい明確に見えるんです
だからイスラム教にしても
キリスト教にしても ユダヤ教にしても
ヒンドゥー教にしても
で 中国のいろいろ宗教あるんですけど
どちらにしてもそれ以外のことは考えられないんですよ
脳っていうのはすごく狭いんですね
例えば日本に最近ものすごく流行っている幸福の科学という宗教にしたっても
全く同じことをより品のないように言うだけ
だから全く論理性 キリスト教だったらそれなりの何か論理成り立ってますけど
そこまでの論理成り立ってないんですね
ですから ただあっちこっちから人の話を盗んで言っただけでね
かっこつけるだけで 日本だからすごくうまくいってますけど
もう外国でそんなこと言っちゃうと
もう 1年も経たないと思いますけどね
潰しちゃいますけどね
反論しますからね ですから
このその人でも まああっちこっちからこの一番面白い次元論があるんですよ
この次元論というのは
ある西洋のなんとかこのへんてこりな宗教があって
そこで一二次元の三次元の世界
四次元の世界 五次元の世界とか何とか言って
魂は六次元の世界とか何か言ってるんです
その話がなんか耳に入っちゃって
耳に入っただけでは足らないと私が思いますけど
徹底的に次元って何なのかと勉強しなきゃ
それでこの人 じゃあ 5 でしょ
私は 6 7 8 9 10 19
まで作るんだと  13 そこでその話を私も言ってる
私はなんで 13 で止まるんですか？これはやっぱり 68 まで伸ばした方がいいよと
だって数増えるだけだからね
そこで自分が 13 の次元の上にして
全ての次元が作った神ですと
そこでもう一人バカが出たら
また 13 だからまたもう 20 はよくないんですね
数字的には だから 7 つ付け加えるんではなくて
あと 14 ぐらい付け加えて
34次元の話をして 俺が 34次元の世界で
だって言ったら同じ理屈でしょうに
だからそういう風にただ数字を言うだけで
もし内容があるんだったら
じゃあ次元の世界何なのか
次元の世界何なのかとか
それ説明できますかと
で 見た見たところで次元って何なのかが分かってないんですよ
次元って何なのかと だから私も立場から言えば
人間の知識ではどう頑張っても次元以外何も理解することはできないんです
次元次元もできないんですよ
我々次元でいるんだから
は分かるはずなんです
それは推測はできるんです
例えばこの線というのは次元なんです
ある時点からある時点まで一直線を引くと
その 1本の線というのは次元なんです
描けますか？線は絶対人間に描けないんです
ですから 次元さえも我々にはもう想像できるだけであって
経験することは不可能なんです
で 次元もまあ次元になりますけど
線描いたらそれは単なる次元で
これ長方形なんですよ
だから長方形しか描けません
どんな細く描いたっても
それが長方形なんです
だから目に見えるんですよ
長方形は次元だと思っても
実際は次元なんです だから見えるんです
次元でなければ あの描いたインクがないんですよ
あのインクがいくら薄くても上に成り立ってるんだから見えるんです
だから 1本の線 この微妙な顕微鏡で見えるぐらい細く描いても
あれは次元の棒なんですよ
だから見えるんです ですから
人間には次元 次元さえも経験できない
次元の話は置いておきましょうと
なのによく喋る 次元まで
だからまあそちらにそうやって次元論なんとか入ってるんだから
じゃあキリスト教より優れているんでしょうかと
というのは そうじゃない
魂がいて 魂のものがある
その立場からは全然脱線してないんです
優れてもないんです その言ってる本人が神様は魂そのものであって
で 自分がこの世界を創って
その世界の中にも入り込んでるんです
だからまあ 私にいろいろお釈迦様が言ったような例えが思い浮かぶんだけど
あまりにもきつすぎだからちょっと遠慮します
そういう話には なんで神がね
そういう低い次元でいる人間の世界に入り込んじゃって
みんなのおかげで生きてるんですかね
これみっともないことなんですけど
気持ち悪いのいいところなんですけど
みんなを助けてあげて
みんなより上のレベルにいるのは当たり前のことなのに
例えばキリスト教の神っていうのは絶対人間に見えません
人間とは何の関わりも持たない
これは自分の息子に任せているんです
息子やらメリー様やらいろいろ弟子たちやら
そちらに任せているのに
神は出てこないんです
というものの立場は守ってますよ
もう可哀想でしょうに
だからそちらのキリスト教にあるその微妙な論理さえも分かってないんですね
ということは 絶対的なものだから
やっぱり作られたもののいろいろ面倒を見たり
いろいろね もうそれはもう
もうちょっと次元低い誰かに頼んでもらわないとね
あんたちょっと頑張ってくださいと
自分が入って でもそれはちょっとなんかあまりにもカッコ悪いっていうか
成り立たないんですね
ですから この私が神であるというふうな話したっても
それはやっぱり神を語る
もう何人かいるんです
インドにもたくさんいるしね
私が神でしょうとかね
韓国にもいるし また日本にもいるしね
大体その国ですよ で 言ってもこのまあ同じ理屈でそんなに脱線してないんで
だからこの 2つのポイント
魂と魂に属するものっていうのは
ずいぶん単純に経典で聞こえるかもしれませんだけど
これはこの厳密に智慧で
このすべて一つのこの科学的にキュッと絞って
何この分類するためにまとめてみるんですね
だからまとめたところで
それから漏れたものはないんです
だからそこら辺はちょっと理解した方がいいんですね
我が心があって 心願のものがあると
そこで 各宗教で真我はどのように説明しても
魂個我はどのような説明
それはどうでもいいんです
その宗教の教理だから
でも基本的な立場はこの 2つです
だからお釈迦様が言うのは
そういう真我があるならば
心願のものもあるっていうことが成り立つでしょう
成り立ちます そこで真我と真我に即する者というものがサッチャと実際に具体的にサッチャが as a reality
事実として テータと またサッチャとテータと
テータっていうのは このテートっていうのは嘘ということなんですけど
そこから作っているこの事実という言葉なんですね
ですから この真理として
事実として 具体的にという意味なんですね
はっきりと 我というものがアヌパラブマナ
例えば調べて調べて調べて調べて
どのように調べても これが我
これが真我というふうなものっていうのは
決して真理として見つからない場合は
アヌパラブマナっていうのは
この見つかるといっても
お釈迦様はすべての方法を考えているんですね
例えば想像して 思考を働かせて
考えて考えて考えて考えて
ただ純粋論理として成り立つという
西洋で論理学ありますね
この西洋の論理学っていうのは
ほとんどこの頭の中だけで考えて考えて作るんですね
特にこの数学というものが出てきて
この数学から論理作るんですね
だから西洋の論理学を勉強するためには
かなり数学の能力も必要になるんですね
だから数学わからないからやめちゃったんです
シンボリックロジックとかありますね
それでシンボリズムで論理も成り立って
並べて並べて並べて  1ページ書いても
それは言葉で書くならば膨大な量になるんです
私はそれは実際にこの practical logicに入れ替えちゃうとどのようになるかというと
ほとんど証拠を見つからないほど厳密に論理するんです
でも数学的に全部成り立つんですよ
そういう本というと こんな分厚い本なんですよ
1ページでも もう数字だけでも
もう何も言葉ない まああるのはまあですから故にとか
それにもシンボル使っちゃうんです
だからそういう風に この純粋に思考だけ考えることだけ使って調べていった時でも
もし結論として見いだせるならば
このアヌパラブマナっていうのはいろんな方法で至るという意味なんですね
ですから これどんな手段でもいいんです
例えば経験で修行でもよろしいし
もう断食でも何でもいいんですね
何か修行やら断食やら何かをしてしてして
あ わかったそうと真我をというふうな
真我のことわかったそうと
そういう経験で言ってもよろしいし
神秘主義で頑張って 神秘主義のもう最終的に達した論理として
それでもよろしいし あるいは単なる我々現代人みたいな唯物論で唯物論でもうよく食べて遊んで楽しく生きてると
もう純粋な純粋たる魂が発見できるそうと言って言うならば
それでもいいんです あるいは宗教を全く否定して
現代人みたいに 純粋たるこの有部説論で食って遊んで寝て死ぬことは究極な魂の幸福ですよと
それでも究極的な真がたる魂が見つかるならば
あるいは全く食べ物食べようともしないで
徹底的に水も何も飲まないで
もう体は全部減ってもらって
減ってもらっちゃうと
無常たるものは減る 本物でないものは消えていく
本物が消えないはずですね
永遠なものは消えないはず
それで一人の人がどこかに座ってでもよろしい
立ってでもよろしい 寝てでもよろしいし
もう水も飲まない ご飯も食べない
それでじーっと待っている
待っているところでどんどん体が減る
それで最終的に魂が残ると
そういう方法でもいいんです
だからこの魂の発見方法っていうのは
どんな方法でもいいんです
そこでお釈迦様が言うのは
それ何かの方法で どんな方法でも
そうやって調べて調べて調べて
最終的に あ 見つかりましたと
金でもね 掘る場合はほとんど金ないんですよ
もう石 土そのものなんですね
それでも知ってる人はわかる
これは金脈だと 金の棒みたいなものを掘ると見つかるわけじゃないんですね
泥やら石やら そういうものを全部持って砕いて砕いて洗って
いろいろ工夫して工夫して
トンぐらいの土を処理したところで
まあキロぐらい もっと低いんですけどね
ほんのちょっと金が見つかりますから
ですから こんなこのトンぐらいのこの土の中に金がありますよと言えますでしょうに
たとえ土見たって何も見つからなくても
だから方法はいいんです
方法はいいんですけど
一応結論が出てくるならばよろしいんですね
だからお釈迦様はこちらでこのアヌパラッバティ
ウパラッバティというのは
という言葉を使ってるんですね
ウパラッバティっていうことは
このいろんな方法で調べたところで得られる結論のことをパーリ語でそういうふうに言うんですね
人自体はお釈迦様いとも簡単に
この深いものをわからないんだからね
難しい論はわからないんだから
ただないとずいぶん勝手に言ったのではないかと
ないというのは簡単ではないか
そういうことじゃないんです
例えば私は信じませんというのはすごい簡単でしょうね
あんたは死後人が生まれ変わる信じる？いや
あれは信じませんよとかね
そういうのは簡単ですよ
幽霊は信じませんよと
でも幽霊が本当にいるかと
いろんな証言集めて集めて
世界中地球上もうそういう証言出る出る所に行って
徹底的に研究して やっぱりないんだという人とまた違うでしょ
その人は幽霊がいると信じてる人よりも研究しているんです
だからこのラッシャナリストソサエティの会長をやっていた人がコールさんという人なんですけど
このもう死んじゃったんだけど
すごい知識人で 神秘的なものは全部否定するんですね
超能力 こういう呪文 科学的でないものはもう一切全部否定する
全部否定するんだけど
バカじゃないんです どこででも行って調べる
あんなところでものすごいこの占い師がいて
すっぱりと占ってくれると言ったら
そこへ行って調べる ある人がこういう風なこのなんとか不思議なことするんだそうと
言ってそこに本人が行く
言って徹底的に調べる
例えば日本にいる大槻教授でもね
あの推文化でそんなものは信じませんということじゃないでしょうに
ちゃんと研究して調べてありえないと
なんか火の玉とかね あれは魂ではないか
あるいはもうプラズマ
それはプラズマ現象でも簡単に作れますよと
で作らせて見せる 何もないところで火の玉が出てくる出てくるのではないかと
ですから その人々はないと言うために
あるという人よりもものすごい頭使ってます
だからないと言う場合は
その二つの立場があるんですよ
愚か者に簡単に怠け者にいえ
ないない信じませんとと言うこともできますけど
知識の究極的なところまで行った人がその結果としてないということと
またその二つの立場がありますね
ですから お釈迦様がこの調べるところは全てもう調べてみて
その上でないということを発見して
ありえないということまで発見してないと言っていることですから
そこであぬパラッバティ
ウパラッバティというパーリ語のこの二つの言葉はそれを意味しているんです
注釈書にしても そのお釈迦様のこの大変さをわかってないと思います
ブッダフル長老の注釈にしたっても
ブッダフル長老たちにしたっても
お釈迦様は信仰しているんだから
やっぱりお釈迦様全部知ってるんだからそれで十分だと
そんな単純なことでもないんです
それは信仰で信じるのは簡単ですけど
お釈迦様にしてみれば
これも大変な仕事 ですから
この言葉一つ一つもものすごい考えて使っているんです
ですから サッチャとテージャトっていうのは
このOntologicalという西洋の哲学的な
このOntologyという立場から考えているんですね
本当に実体として 実体論ですね Ontology
っていうのはね で その
そうやって実体として見当たらない
成り立たない いくら研究しても
いくら調べても その結論には至らないという
もし至らないならば 実体があるという結論には全く至らないならば
ヤンピダン・ディッティッターナ
どうですか この世の中である考え方があります
ディッティッターナ ディッティっていうのは見ですね
仏教で邪見に使いますけど
これこそ正しいやと 何かの意見にしがみつくことはディッティと言うんですね
だから この意見にはしがみついてはいけないということは
仏教は大変厳しく言っているんですね
で 我々はこの一時的な真理っていうのは腐るほどあるんです
だから我々の人生っていうのは
いつでも一時的な真理に成り立っているんですよ
人が何かしてくれたら
あんた優しいですねと言うんです
それによって その人は絶対的に優しいというわけじゃないんです
それでも この人はもう絶対的に優しい人だ
これで決まりだ 終わりだと
もう終結やっていうのはもうバカバカらしくて
まあその場で優しいですねということで
それは誰も反対はしません
何か失礼なこと あんた本当に失礼な人ですね
行儀が悪いんだよと 言ったら
その一時的なんです その場で
その場で その環境で その人がやったことが行儀が悪いというふうな意見になる
そういうふうな世界で我々は生きているので
それでよく失敗する ある時はあの人は行儀が悪いと
証拠が出てきても 我々はそれが頭の中で覚えておいて
ずっと持ち運ぶんです
その意見が Aさんは行儀が悪いと
それで我々はトラブル作っちゃうんですね
だから意見というのは一時的なもので
その条件の中にのみ成り立たないんですね
だからそれを忘れているんだから
世の中でありとあらゆる戦い
悩み 苦しみ ぶつかり合いっていうのは出てくる
全てそういうものなんですね
何々さんが随分綺麗な人ですよと
我々言う みんな ああ それはそうですね
あの人は随分すごく綺麗な人ですよと
で 大勢の人々はその人は綺麗やと認めるかもしれません
でも 何々さんが綺麗な人ですよということは
あくまでも一時的な論理であって
それが永世的な永遠に変わらない事実ということになりません
だから 全てのものはそういうふうな真理
科学の真理も全て絶対的な真理ではありません
全て条件の中で成り立つ真理なんですね
条件が外れたらもうそれは成り立たないんですね
だからディッティっていうのは
そのある 証拠があって
何かの結論に至ってしまって
それが絶対的な真理として持っていこうとする
そこは仏教とはやらないんですね
仏教とはやらないので
それも大変な智慧なんです
大変な智慧なんです だから世の中のことを否定する必要も
肯定する必要もないんです
この魂があるんだ 魂があるんだという人々もね
何かの経験に基づいて言うんだけど
その経験何なのかとかね
見てみるだけのことだ
お釈迦様もものすごい残酷に魂否定したわけなくて
その当時にいた修行者の修行の経験というのを全て認めています
この絶対的な邪見を語っている人々よりも
邪見はバカにするんだけど
修行は認めているんです
だから修行を認めて なんで修行の結果とすること
結論付けているんでしょうか
そこはお釈迦様はすごいところなんです
その人は一生懸命いろいろ断食までして飲まず食わず頑張ったところは
それはよく頑張りましたと
そこで確かにその人はこれぐらい心集中しているんだと
そこで一般の人々に見えない
経験できない こういういろんなことをこの人は経験しているんですよと
でも彼がその身近で この狭い
この小さな経験に基づいて
この普遍的な真理を作ったところは
これはバツですよ これが間違いだと
で それは中部経典の中部経典の読むと
その理屈 論理はわかりますよ
例えば過去生を見られる能力を得る
仏教だけじゃなくて 他宗教にもそれはあったんですよ
瞑想して このレトロコグニションと英語で言うんですけど
心を過去に回転させるという訓練をする
で 心を過去に回転させる訓練しちゃうと
自分の過去は明確に直接経験します
そういう経験の多次元的な経験で
この現在 この多次元論を喋る人々にはわからないんです
過去を見るということはね
だからこの本人にとってはもうはっきりとすごい明確に
鮮明に 具体的に この心にそのその経験は映るんです
いわゆる心は回転するだけ
もう終わった世界だからね
終わった世界だから また戻すわけにはいきません
世界っていうのはもう変化して変化していくんだから
この移動っていうものはあんまり成り立たないんですよ
ですから この心は過去に回転すると
そのその瞬間で心はどんな反応をしたかというね
反応はその人を感じるんです
だから直接経験なんです
それで後でその人にそれを言葉入れて
もう何億年前 私はこういう風にいましたよということでも
後で言えるんですね その時は自分がその経験の中に入ってるんですね
入って 心は後ろに回転させちゃうんですね
それでこの 例えばそのその個人が自分の過去を見ても
そのその個人の過去しか見られないんですね
そこである人が自分の過去を見る
過去を見ると 例えば梵天とかね
そういうところに過去に生まれていたんだということを自分で発見するんですね
梵天というのもまた多次元の世界で
たくさん梵天 梵天界があるんですね
そのその梵天界によって心の回転というのは変わっちゃうんですね
大体ほとんど梵天に生まれ変わったら
複数の感情っていうのは生まれません
ずっとサマーディ状態みたいな
一定の心の回転なんですね
同じ心はずっと回転する
我々の音が聞くと心が変わる
人が見ると心が変わる
我々の心っていうのは
瞬間瞬間激しく変化するんですね
で 変化は同じく変化あるんだけど
梵天などになったら変化はあるんだけど
波は同じ波で回転するんですね
私たちと違って 我々怒りの波を出す
欲を出すと まるっきり正反対でしょうね
何か好きでたまらない時の心と
嫌で嫌でもう我慢できない時の心っていうのはすごい波が違う
だからそういう風に分かりやすい変化がないんだよ
同じく流れてる 例えば川でも流れるということは
見えるのは石があったり
上下があったり いろいろ湾曲があったりすると
水が流れるということ見えますね
本当にフラットなところで
まるっきり綺麗な水 一滴の泡も立たないで流れるとこはわからないんです
水が流れてるんだっていうこと
だから梵天になったとこを覚えたら
その人はまたそこで心を後ろに回転してみるんですね
どこに後ろに回転しても同じ心を見つかるんですね
だから回転してもしてもしてもしてもしても同じこと
そこでももう億単位で年代をね
それぐらい時間回転してみても
それで諦めちゃうんです
まあこれいくら後ろに行っても
まあこれ同じものやと
誰でももう諦めちゃう
見ても見ても見ても見ても同じものだったら
もういい加減諦めましょうと同じやと
そこで彼が瞑想をやめて
やっぱり自分が経験しましたと
過去で永遠たる魂 私は永遠たる魂でいたんだよと
今人間にいるんだけど
だからお釈迦様が彼の結論が間違いやと
でも修行した部分は まあそれはもう認め
それは経験は正しい 経験は正しいんだけど
結論が間違っているんだよという
微妙なところで言ってるんですね
それディッティッターナという言葉も
仏教の世界では大変大事なことで
私はこの大事大事という言葉というのは
現代みんな知ってる仏教では大事にしていない世界
四聖諦とか十二因縁の言葉とかね
そういういくつかしか大事にしてないんですね
初期仏教にすれば それで大乗仏教は大乗仏教のなんとかなんとかの概念だけ考えて
それでお互いに誤解ばっかしで話し合いばっかしで終わるんだけど
もう誰一人も気づいてない
お釈迦様のこの人間として
もう全く誰にも比べられないほどの
この超越した智慧の世界と
その見方とか そこら辺の言葉にはあんまり気づいてないんですね
だからどんな仏教のテキストを読んでみても
まあ四聖諦の話やらね
八正道の話とかね そこら辺で終わっちゃう
そうすると なんだそれぐらいのことかと
と終わってしまっちゃうんで
それは大乗仏教もテーラワーダ仏教を批判するんで
その人々は小問情で四聖諦のことしかわからないで
空なんかわからないんだと
仏神なんかはわからないんだとかなんとか言っちゃうしね
だからどちらでもどうかなと聞きたいところもありますけどね
で 注釈書をなんか読んでみたって
こういうこの微妙なところにお釈迦様は見せている
この巨大な智慧っていうのは注を入れてないんですね
入れられないこともありますけどね
で 当時でそういう思考パターンもなかったしね
それでディッティッターナ
まあ注釈だったら これはもう邪見それで済みます
邪見と言っただけで これで済んだっていうことになりません
だからなぜディッティというんでしょうかというと
この見つかったこと それは事実真理なんですけど
それが真理だと持ち運んだ瞬間で邪見になっちゃうんですね
持ち運べないんです だからどんな真理でも
この全て一時的で 永遠というわけにはなりません
だから科学の真理でも同じことで
例えば今もみんな踏ん張ってますけど
邪見に基づきてもういっぱい車作って品物をいっぱい作って売りさばいて儲かってみます
儲かってみますとかね
経済成長 またなんとかやりますとか
これも邪見だからこういうひどい目に遭ってるんです
だから存じりシステム全部もうぐるっと変えちゃうと
この邪見になりません
だから頭がいいんだ 技術があるんだ
能力あるんだとかで 自慢しているだけで
そんなに技術能力あるんだったら燃やすてエネルギー作る
この機械 石油燃やしてエネルギー作るでしょうにね
それとこの電気で回る
その二つからいまだに脱出していないでしょうに
だからどうやって低公害車作る？低公害といっても公害ですから
それほど技術能力あるんだったら
ちょっと頭だけちょっと洗ってみれば
新しい思考をいくらでもできるはずなんです
だからかなり昔 この回転ということを発見しちゃって
それで全ての機械 回転法則でしょ
どんな機械見ても回転法則
でも心臓を見てください
回転法則じゃないんです
体は回転法則で動いてるわけじゃないんですけど
伸び縮み法則でやっているんですね
だから伸び縮み法則でも人間作っている機械っていろいろありますけど
バイブレーターやらね
このアラームやらね そういうものっていうのは伸び縮み法則でやってますけどね
だからこのとにかくそんなことどうでもいいんですけど
これこそやと思って止まっちゃうと
もうそこでもう発展もストップしちゃうんですね
ですから 車だったら必ず石油を燃やさなくちゃいけないということが事実ではありません
石油を回さなくても移動する何か他の形の機械っていうのは考えれば作れないわけじゃないんです
だからこの絶対的な真理というの成り立たないんです
全く公害のないエネルギーは原子力エネルギーだとね
これ日本ではよくよく言うんですね
公害のないエネルギーは水力というんですか
それと原子力と で 原発と
そうでしょうかね 水力発電も公害なんですけど
あれ だって水を流れていくべき水をあっちこち溜まってもらって
それで泥を溜まってたまって
それで自然は公害破壊になりますけど
原発は公害ではないんですかね
だからこの今現代我々でも苦しんでいる理由は
一つの真理発見して あ
見つかったぞ 見つかったぞ
これこそ真理や これこそ真理やとしがみつく
真理を持ち運ぶ それの問題なんです
持ち運んではいけませんというのが仏教の立場なんですね
それはその条件の中にのみ通用する真理だよと
条件変わったら違いますよと
だから今までは石油を燃やすエネルギーは大変ありがたい幸福の泉やと
それは過去の話で 現在将来の話ではありません
だから金こそ金だよと言っていたのは
これ過去の話で 今は金っていうのはね
別に金っていうことで考えてないんですね
だからそういう風にもうゆっくり変わることはありますけど
全ての真理で 特に人間関係の場合
我々はもう激しく人が悪いことしたら
あの人悪い人やってもう決めて
もうレッテルを貼って
もう判子を押して もうシールも貼って終わりにするんですね
もう決めた もう終わり
その人は悪い そういう生き方で我々苦しんでるんですね
そういう哲学だから だからこの食べ物美味しいんですよ
食べましょうというのは決して悪いことじゃないんです
その瞬間でいいと判断しなきゃできませんだから
でもこの食べ物美味しいですよ
食べましょうと言っても
それで永久的に死ぬまでこれ食べるぞと思っちゃうと
それでその人死んじゃうんです
早くも ですから この意見というのはそういうこと
だからこの運ぶことでよって
意見というのはディッティになるんです
だからディッティターナという言葉を使っているんです
ターナっていうのはよりどころにしている
ある意見を自分のよりどころにしている
その言葉の意味で そこで普通の経典に戻りますけど
この世の中で実際に具体的に真我っていうのは見つからないならば
この世の中である意見があります
ディッティターナとして絶対的な意見
全く変わらない意見がという
これこそ唯一の真理で
もう絶対的な真理だというふうにみんな考えている
信仰している意見がありますよ
それはどういう意見かというと
そう労苦そうあった こちらで労苦っていうのは世界という風に訳するかもしれませんだけど
生命界なんですね 一切の生命の世界
一切の生命の世界とあったがは同一ものであると
だから労苦と言えば 労苦っていうのは世界っていう意味なんですけど
この生命と 解をね 全部まとめて全てのせいまとめてこの老工っていう風に言っちゃうんですね
ですから この真我のことを言ってるんです
梵歌のことを言ってるんです
でお釈迦様は梵歌とかなんとか使ってないんで
その言葉出てこないんです
ウパニシャッドでは散々出ているんだけど
仏典では出てこないんですね
それで学者が言うのは
やっぱりお釈迦様は勉強していないんだと
それをもう学者が勉強してないことであって
学者にはこの固定概念があるんですね
ウパニシャッドっていうのは仏教よりすごく古い哲学思想だと
仏教はそんなに古い素晴らしい哲学ということではありませんと
ウパニシャッドっていうのは仏教より古くないんです
本当に客観的に研究してみていると
で ブッダの時代でいくらかできてあったウパニシャッドっていうのは三つしかないんです
それもウパニシャッドに成り立ってないアーランニャカテキストのブリハダランヤカ・ウパニシャッドというウパニシャッドあります
これアーランニャカという名前まで入っている
アーランニャカというテキストのグループあります
だからブリハドというアーランニャカ
まだウパニシャッドでもありますということで
そういうチャーンディョーグ・ウパニシャッド
ブリハダランヤカ・ウパニシャッド
で イシャ系の言葉はそうでしたから
もう一つあります その二つ三つぐらいですね
まあそれも完全にブッダの時代より古いということを本当は言えませんだけど
一応学者が決めちゃったんだからね
やっぱりウパニシャッドは古いと決めたんだから
その邪見をずっと我々は研究に使わなくちゃいけないんですね
例えばこの間の放送大学でこの宗教のことを見ていたんですけど
かなり研究した人はいるんですけど
大乗仏教と南伝の仏教のところに行っちゃうと
やっぱりもう決まってる邪見で言うんですね
大乗仏教は慈悲の教えで
多少の苦痛 解脱のために一生懸命頑張っている教えであって
で この南伝なんか そこら辺の国々に広がっているのは
この部派仏教 明確にそれは部派仏教で出家主義で
自分だけの悟りに行って頑張っているんだと
出家だから仕事をやら何もしませんだから
在家の人々を支えなくちゃいけないんだと
それで在家と出家は まあそういうふうに
もう王様やらみんなその出家者を支えている
それはもう南伝の今言ってる部派仏教の世界で
大乗仏教は慈悲の慈悲と智慧の教えだよと
で この間スリランカ人も私達に攻撃したんだけどね
テーラワーダ仏教だから国が発展しませんと
大乗仏教の国はすごくすごく発展しているんだと
例として出すのは日本とかね
だから私はたくさん問題が出します
発展ということをあんた方わかってるんですかと
発展というのは建物いっぱい作ることかと
工場がいっぱい作ることかと
それが発展ですかと あんた方はどんな基準で日本やらね
もう台湾やらね 大乗仏教の国々は発展していると言うんでしょう
それは誰が決めた基準ですかと
結局それは西洋人が作った基準でしょうと
はい 次に じゃあその基準で発展と決めるならば
どれぐらい建物あるか
月の月々収入は数字でどれぐらいですかと
食べる室はどうでもいいんです
額だけ大きければ皆様方も万
万単位で収入収入はありますけど
結局苦労して苦労して
全部もう帳簿をごまかして生きてるんだから
だから月々に 二百万円収入あったって同じことでしょうに
どうしようどうしようとかね
そんなことをもうマスシーっていう国で同じことなんで
明日どうしようかな ご飯食べなくちゃいけないし
子供に服買ってあげなくちゃ
お金がないからとかね
ちょっと借りてみましょうとかね
日本もそんなもんでしょうね
みんな借金で品物買ってるでしょ
冷蔵庫買っても何買っても借金で買ってるでしょうね
だからこのものごとをもっと見てほしいんですよ
だから総じて見れば 日本人の月々の収入とスリランカ人の三年の収入ぐらいなんです
でもあれで三年間生きてますよ
こちらで月々の収入でなんとかとかね
ですから このそれは西洋人がこの数学的に好き勝手に考えたもので
とことん自然を破壊することは発展やと
でも初期仏教やらテーラワーダ仏教の世界では守ることを大事やと
植物も動植物も何から何まで自然を壊さないようにという
昔からそういう考えでいたんです
壊すなよと 木一本でも倒してはあかんと
それでも家を建てるためには木を倒さなくちゃいけないんですよ
そうするとみんなお願いしてね
申し訳ないんだとか あなたをとことんもう切っちゃいますよと
だから まあやっぱりこれぐらい大きくして
これぐらいバカでかい家作りましょうとかね
それはできないんです
どれぐらい消せるかと
木も五本倒さなくちゃいけないところ
これ何とか四本にできませんかとと考えちゃうんです
だから発展のように見えないんです
屋根がいらないんだったら屋根が作らないんですよ
屋根は何のためだと まあ雨ぐらい漏れないでだったらそれぐらい十分だと
例えば日本の瓦の屋根とかあるでしょ
あれの作りを私が見ると
屋根一つ作る時使う材料とお金で自分の国だったら家五軒作れます
屋根だけに使うお金で
いとも簡単に だからそれは向こうにあるのはとにかく消す論理で
なぜ消すかというと 自然を大事に守っておきましょうという
まあそれもいいと言えば仏教の思想なんですけど
だから私が言いたいのは
どちらが正しいかっていうか
そこはちょっとそんな簡単には言いにくいんです
一人の人がね もう四十個ぐらい部屋あるバカでかい家を作って
俺が豊かだと言っても
本当にあれで豊かですかねと
それは人類にそういう風に建物作れますかね
それ自体無理でしょうね
一人だけ凶暴な人がバカでかい土地を買って
バカでかい建物を建てて
スイミングプールも三個ぐらい作ると
住んでるのは三人だけですと
と言って それが豊かさ
豊かさという基準自体が非経済学なんですよ
なぜならば万人にそれ無理でしょうに
でもどうにもならないんだけど
一本だけ木をいただきますと
じゃあ二本 私は子供四人いますから
じゃあ二本いただきますという世界だったら
万人に生きていられますけど
動植物にも生きていられますけど
だから地球上の全ての人類に
全ての生命に気楽に悩むことなく
明日のことが悩むことなく生きていられる哲学と
体中燃えて燃えて もう落ち着けない
生きてる西洋型の経済学
どちらがいいかと それそういう話いっぱいあるにも関わらず
平気でもうこう言っちゃったんですね
テーラワーダのせいでマスシーやと
そこで私はあなた方もうちょっと研究して言ってくださいと
一つだけでも例を私に言ってください
日本は本当に西洋の基準では二番目にくる豊かな国ですよと
経済成長からね それでこの日本の今の経済的な豊かさには
日本の仏教の思想から
これ一つのワンポイント
これが支えてあげたと
応援したんだと 一つだけでも教えてください
寺が貢献した部分が 誰も研究してないんだから逆なんですけど
で それは日本のお坊様方が悪いってわけじゃなくて
その教えの問題なんです
例えば両道心 南無阿弥陀仏宗
南無阿弥陀仏の教えと経済発展
どうやってつながるんですか？経済発展
会社の経営にナムアミダブス思考役に立ちますよ
どうやって役に立つんですかね
だって頑張るなよって言ってるんだから
悪人は先に救われますよって言ってるんだから
早く死んだ方がいいでしょうに
浄土真宗によると それで極楽道に行くんだから
だから人に頑張れ 努力して神に祈るなよと
お前の幸せは自分のあなたの出す汗にかかるんだよというのお釈迦様でしょうに
人間仲良くしなさいよと
怒りなんか感情に負けるなよと
感情に勝ちなさいよって言ってるの誰ですかね
私は結論を言ったらあなた方が悪いんだ
頭が悪すぎやと 大事な仏教を理解しなかったんだから間違うてるんだよと
仏教を理解してならば
もう世界に新しい経済学さえ教えてあげることさえもできたのに
間違いはあなた方にあるんだよと
仏教にあるわけじゃないんだと
どうってわけで仏教のことはと
で 私は十分ぐらいでもうまとめて喋って終わっちゃった
まあそこまで余計な話ばっかりで申し訳ないんですけど
また話戻りますけど 世界全部まとめて魂として
その魂 世界といったって生命ですね
生命は魂ということで
この絶対真我 アッターっていうのは自分の個我なんですね
ソウル・ロー・コー・ソー・アッター
真我も個我も同じですよと
いわゆる梵我一如ということなんです
でも仏典では梵我一如という言葉は出てこないんです
ソーローコーソーアッター
ローコーっていうのは真我
アッターっていうのは個我なんです
だから二つも同じや そこで個我があって
私には個我がありますね
個人の我 それで私は死んじゃったら
その個我がずっと飛んでいって真我に入り込んじゃう
今真我に行けないんですよ
体でこのちょっと掴まれてるんだから
そこで死んじゃったら体が壊れてもうバラバラになるでしょう
そうするとこの個我がずっと行って真我と一緒になると
だからこのウパニシャッドとして発展したのはその哲学なんです
後でこの梵我一如というね
言葉は後で出たんですね
ブラフマンとアートマンというね
タットワマシ エイタットブラフマンという風にウパニシャッドははっきりとブラフマンブラフマンと言うんですね
アートマンアートマンと個我を言うんですね
お釈迦様の時代では そこまで哲学的な固定した用語が出ていなかっただろうと思います
あれは当時でも実際にみんな毎日実践している
このプラクティカルな哲学でしたから
その梵我一如論でもね
ただ頭で分かってわかりもしないで勉強する世界ではなかったのが
みんな真剣真面目に毎日を生活の中でも考えてやっていたものだからね
だからそういう風にすごいわかりやすい言葉でお釈迦様は使っているんです
そこでテッチェ・バヴィッサン
テッチェ 死んでからこうなりますと
ニッチョー・ドゥオ ニッチョー
常住 永遠 ドゥオっていうのは不死
サッサト サッサトってまたこれも永遠という意味なんですね
エターナルというふうに訳しますね
永遠エターナル まあ無限というかね
終わりなく アヴィパリーナハ・ダンム
変化することなく それでまた訳します
わかりやすく 真我があって個我があって同じものだ
故に私が死んじゃったら
私は永遠になります 変わらないものになります
絶対的なものになります
死後 そんなに難しい話じゃないんです
だから 人間として個人個人には個があります
その個が老個という絶対的な生命体の中には真我があって
真我そのものが絶対的世界というふうな真我なんですね
それは絶対的な我と私の個我っていうのは同一もの
だから体壊れちゃったらすぐ絶対的な我になってしまう
まあウパニシャドに戻って説明します
皆様方はそこら辺私よりはプロやと思いますけど
でも私のこの素人の説明にはウパニシャドのプロとも勝てません
こちらには空気があるんですね
どこにでも満遍なく空気がありますね
それで何か持ってきて
私は例えば風船でもよろしいしね
風船が持ってきて風船を膨らませておく
膨らませて結んでおく
それで風船の中にも何がありますか？空気がありますね
どちらにあった空気ですか？風船の空気は
この部屋にあった空気でしょう？ここら辺に満遍なくあった空気が今風船の中にも一部あるんであって
だから決して風船の中にある空気は別なものではありません
風船の中に空気が入ったんだからといって
こちらにあった空気が減ったわけでもないんです
ただ同じ空気なんです
ただ空気の中にちょっと風船の皮というかね
あのスキンがそれはちょっとなっただけで
だから部屋の空気 たとえ風船の中にあろうか
ガラスの中にあろうか
それも関係ないんです
どんな入れ物にあるかと
そこで風船を針で穴を開けてしまう
開けちゃうと風船がボンと割れる
割れたら何か不思議なことが起こりますかね
何も起こりません ただ風船の皮が割れただけ
空気はそのまま 何のことなく
この大きな空気と一緒になるだけ
そこで幻想的に 我々には別に空気が風船の中にあるのごとく錯覚する
それは錯覚 風船が作る錯覚
別に風船の中に空気と部屋の空気が別にいるわけじゃないんです
元々 元々一緒にいるものです
でも風船自体がちょっと錯覚する
その辺に我々に体があるんで
それはその風船と同じで
この別なものやと錯覚を起こしていて
この体が割れちゃうと風船が割れたと同じく真我に一入になると
すごい単純だと わかりやすくそういうことなんです
ウパニシャドが教えているのは
だからこの梵我一如・真我一入の論はそれぐらいの論理なんです
それ理解して勉強してみると
ものもっと明確にわかります
今までわからなかった何々論
何々論というのはもう簡単にわかるんです
まずこの哲学作る人の脳細胞をつかまっておかないと
だからこの何でも勉強する方というのはそういう方法なんです
何しようがこの脳細胞でやっていることだと
その人の脳の働きをつかまっておく
そしたらその人は何を言ってるか
それからもう簡単にわかります
ですから この真我一如論というのは
そういうふうな論理で成り立つんですよ
それで各宗教で 各宗派で
ヴァイシュナビ様がいろいろイーシュワラを信仰する世界
いろいろヒンドゥーの教でもね
もうわからないんですけども
何万宗派があるかっていうことはね
いろいろ教えがもう猿を信仰するは
もうネズミを信仰するは
牛を信仰するは いろいろ
どちらにあったっても
基本的な考え方は同じなんですね
ヒンドゥーの人々っていうのはこの宗派がたくさんあるんだけど
宗派の間では争わないんです
一人が猿を信仰して こちら一人座って牛を信仰している
お互いには喧嘩しません
その代わりにイスラム教とやり合っちゃう
キリスト教とやり合っちゃうというところがけしからんところなんですね
で 仏教はもっとけしからんで
仏教は同じ宗派の間で喧嘩するんですね
ヒンドゥー教はもうちょっと品がいいんですけどね
[笑い]そこでこのそのディッティッターナ
個我と身我があって 死後身我になって永遠不滅になるんだぞという
この考え方は もし我がなければ
我が成り立たないならば
我が見いだせないならば
何でしょうかね ケーバロ・パリプーナ・バーラダンも完璧なアホな教えではないかと
アホのいいところというところじゃないでケーバロ
もうもう絶対的に愚か者の考え方ではないかと
だってまるっきり我がないという状態だったら
身我 個我って成り立たんでしょうに
個我は身我になるんだぞ
それを信仰でいくんだと言ったら
それほど愚かな考え方はないでしょうと
だから比丘たちもそうでしょうと
それでお釈迦様のこの厳密な論理は単純な一両で終わってしまって
お釈迦様にはすぐに問題が出てくるんですね
お釈迦様がおっしゃったんだから
我っていうのは成り立たない
見いだせない どんな風に研究してみても
その結論には至れないというウパラブベティ
そのコンクルージョンに
その結論に至ることはできないと
できないならばと言ったんだからね
そこでお釈迦様にはすぐにチャレンジがかかっています
我が見いだせないということを説明しなくちゃいけないんです
じゃあ研究しましょうと
世の中 世の中を研究すると我が見つかりますかと
それでお釈迦様は自分の研究にいくんですね
タンキンマンヤタ・ビククエ・ルーパ・ニッチャンワ・アニッチャンワ
君たちはどのように思いますか？ルーパはニッチェ
永遠ですか？アニッチャン
無常ですか？と ルーパは変化しないパーマネントのものですか？あるいは無常なものですかと
このpermanentという言葉なんですけど
英語で使うのはpermanent
もう永久ということなんです
そこでルーパというものが色ですね
永遠ですか？無常ですか？と聞くんですね
ルーパというのはどちらかというと
誰にでもわかるこの物体のこと
体の物体のこと だから個我とか私とか言っても
まず我々にははっきり研究対象になるのは物体としての体なんですね
それが永遠のものですか
変わるものですかと わかりますね
そんなそれぐらいは もう体が変わるんだということは
そこで変わりますよと
ヤンパナ・アニッチャン
ドゥッカンワ・スカンワと
すぐ変わるものであるならば
それが苦で受け取るべきですか
幸福として受け取るですかと
いわゆるスカっていうのは永遠な幸せ
幸福ですね 瞬時に変わるものだったら
それは永遠な幸せ 幸福だと受け取るべきものですか
あるいは何の意味もない無意味なもの
ドゥッカというのは無意味なものですからね
だからお釈迦様は苦しいという意味でドゥッカ使ってないんです
無意味 不完全 どうったことないという意味でね
使ってます ですから すぐ変わるものだったら
そんなものは大変幸福というべきものか
あるいはドゥッカか 無意味な下らんものやと見るべきですかと
すぐ変わるもんだったら
それはドゥッカだよと
自分たちが決める お釈迦様決めるんじゃなくて
ヤンパナ アニッチャン ドゥッカン ヴィパリーナマダンマン
それで何かものがアニッチャン
無常であって ドゥッカン
ドゥッカであって ヴィパリーナマダンマン
すぐ変わってしまう 変化するものであるならば
カッランウンタン サムノパッセトン
このように観察するべきか
エータンママ これが私です
エスーハマスメ 私がこれでありますと
エスーメーアッタ 私の我がこれで在ると言うべきですかと
これはそのまま言っても日本語でちょっとわかりにくくなりますから
逆にしないと そこで逆にして考えてください
ルーパは無常であって空なんですね
ですから無常でもあるし
空でも無意味でもあるしね
だったらその無常たるもの
無意味であるもの そんなものが魂
魂 私 私 身が 身が 個が 個がとかね
そんなにありがたがるべきものですかと
見たらいい それはそんなありがたがるもはっきりしていますからね
ですから体が身我でない個我でもないということをはっきりするんです
ちょっと見ただけで体が変化していくんだから
変化しないものというのは何一つもないんだから
だから体が個我でないこと
身我でないことは お釈迦様にとってははっきりする
こちらで書いてないと思いますけど
このルーパっていうのは物質的なことであって
自分の体なんですけど
その同時に同じ論理で他人の体も同じことを見れば変わるでしょうに
そこで形あるものはすべて変わるでしょうに
地球見ても宇宙を見てもほとんど物質でできているでしょうに
物質でできているものは必ずしも変化するということはもうはっきりしているでしょうに
太陽は地球よりは随分長い時間いるんだけど
ずっと変化しているです
地球よりも変化しているです
変化激しい 他の惑星やら他の星々やら
何だかんだいくら巨大であろうとも
もう変わることははっきりしているんですね
ですから 物質的なすべてのものが他の経典になると
お釈迦様そう言うんです
だから内であろうか 外であろうか
過去であろうか 将来であろうか
微妙な素粒子のレベルの物質であろうか
巨大な宇宙みたいな大型の物質であろうか
無常は無常ですよと 故に一切色無常として理解しなさいよと
本当はそんな調子で説法してはいかんですけど
人が話に乗ってくると
どんどんそれは私も説明できますけど
そうすると心は解脱の方向へ向くんです
ただ中途半端で聞くと
そこはもったいないしね
それはもう大変お釈迦様に対して失礼なんです
ですから ちょっとそこら辺説明変えますけど
2番目に行きます ヴェーダナーに行くんですね
ヴェーダナーというのは体の感覚ですね
痛いやら楽しいやと体で感じるもの
世界ですね 感受する それでも私がではヴェーダナーは知ってます
ジュウは知ってます 常に感じているんだから
ヴェーダナーというもの
ジュウが 感覚がどうでしょうか
永遠でしょうかと 聞いただけでも
そんな永遠じゃない いつでも感覚は変わるんだから
感覚と言うんだから みるみるうちに感覚が変わっていく
ですからそれは無常です
ですから 感覚そのものも永遠な魂として私ってしようと見る必要がないんだと
魂を見いだせませんね
ヴェーダナーの次はサンニャーですね
サンニャーというのは
私はその時その時の気持ちで定義変えますからね
最近入れている定義っていうのは概念ですか
頭の中で我々いっぱい概念持ってますね
その概念持ってるんだから
自我が構成されちゃって生きてますしね
ですから 概念がなければテープレコーダーはテープレコーダーと分からなくなっちゃうんです
概念がなければ 本は本だと分からなくなっちゃうんです
それで我々はこれは本だ
これは桜の木だ これは建物は
これは人間だとかね これは何々さんだとか
そうやって区別の世界は知ってるんです
学校に行って勉強することによって
この区別能力 分別能力をどんどん増えてもらうんです
そこで学校終わってからも新聞
雑誌読んだり いろんな本を読んだりして
我々は何をやってますかというと
分別能力をどんどんどんどん広げていくんです
だから光るものは何でも金だと思っているのは
分別能力ない人なんですよ
子供なんです 子供には金紙も金もそれほど差がないんです
子供にとっては金で作ったものをおもちゃにあげるよりは
もっと軽いものに金紙を綺麗に貼ってきちんとしてあげた方が子供はもっと喜ぶんです
こちらの方がいいんだと
大きくて軽くてと でも大人だったら金紙で作った大きいものよりは小さな金の方がこの方がいいやと
大きくてもこれは結構ですよと言っちゃうし
それで大人には分別能力があるんですね
それはいろんなことを勉強したんだからそうなってくるんでしょうし
ですから 我々はこのずっと物事を区別する能力
分別する能力というものは身についています
それでもって生きているんですよ
今 朝で 今もう何でしたっけ
今時半ですよとかね 午後ですよとか
そういう風なこの全ての知識というかね
それはサンニャなんですね
だからもうはっきりしてはサンニャはわかりませんとか言えるところじゃないんです
朝指さしてこれは何ですかと聞いてもわかるでしょうに
上にこれ何ですかと聞いてもわかるでしょうに
サンニャがなければ道路に行っても歩けませんよ
こちら右でこちら左とわかりませんだから
上原の駅に行く人だったら右に行かなくちゃいけないし
バスに乗る人だったら右に行かなくちゃいけないし
幡ヶ谷の駅には左に行かなくちゃいけないとか
それは全てサンニャなんです
我々いとも簡単にやっています
だから赤ちゃんにさえそれあるんですよ
赤ちゃんにサンニャがなければどうやっておっぱい吸うんですかね
赤ちゃんがいくら小さくたっても
母親の体の中であっちこっち動いて回ってちゃんとおっぱいが見つかるんですから
目でも別に目で見ようってそんな気持ちもない
とにかくそれぐらい分別能力がありまして
それでおっぱい見つかるんですね
ですから それが大きくなればなるほど
その分別能力はどんどん大きくなる
それがサンニャということなんですね
仏教で それは常に私たちにあることで
それでもって私たちは自分と人格という
なんとか妄想するんですね
だから法律を勉強した人が
私は弁護士やというふうに人格を作っちゃう
サンニャのことなんです
医学を勉強して 私は医者ですとというふうに思ったりもする
ですから それはサンニャの世界
お釈迦様のこのサンニャが永遠ですか
変わりますかと 無常ですかと
どうでしょうかね サンニャは変わらないでしょうかね
サンニャっていうのははっきりと変わるもんですね
皆さん変わりたくないと思っているかもしれませんだけど
サンニャが変わらなかったら勉強さえできないでしょうに
これは危ないよと これで遊びなさいと子供に教えたところで
子供にはサンニャは永遠不滅で変わらないだったらわからないんです
我は サンニャが無常だから
子供は新しいサンニャを作る
ここで私たちはなぜ勉強できたかというと
これ無常のおかげなんです
サンニャがずっとぐるぐるぐるぐる変わる
でも増える一方ですかね
サンニャは 増える一方ではないんですよ
いろんなものは知ってるつもりですけども
とっくに忘れているとかね
だから常に新しいサンニャが生まれてくるし
古いサンニャーが忘れていっちゃうし
当てにならないし だから体と同じなんです
ずっと変わっていくでサンニャー
で 3番目 それでサンニャーが私の我やと思うなよと
思うのは意味がないというところで
それでサンカーラになってくるんですね
サンカーラっていうのは
私の最近の訳はこの衝動ですか
生きる時の出てくる生きる衝動なんですね
とにかく何かやりたいんですね
ずっとあるんですね 何か何かやりたい
やりたい それもまたぐるぐるぐるぐる変わるんですね
喋りたい 考えたい 立ちたい
座りたい ご飯食べたい
寝たいとか いつでも瞬間瞬間常に生きるということは何かやることなんです
吸ったら吐きたくなる
吐いたらまた吸ったくなる
呼吸瞑想する時でもそのサンカーラが見えてくるんです
吐きたいんだから吐いていること
吸いたいんだから吸っていることっていうのは
呼吸瞑想の中でも出てきます
ですからサンカーラっていうのはこのそれものの衝動なんですね
それもはっきりしてはっきりしていて
ものすごいわかりやすいものなんです
いつでも心の中であるんですよ
もうなんとか次のことしたいという
ずっとあるんですね だからでそれは永遠ですかというと
そうじゃない いつでも変わるんだから
もう立ちたいと思った人はまた座りたいとなる
永遠だったら立ちたいと立った人は永久的に立っているはずなんですよ
立ちたいと思ったら 立ちたいという衝動が消えちゃって
座りたいという症状に変わるんですね
ご飯食べたいなという症状が生まれたら
ずっとそれでその衝動でご飯食べっぱなしかというと
そうじゃないんです 食べると
いい やめたいという衝動が生まれてくるんですね
それでやめちゃうしね
だからもうサンカーラ自体がずっと変わるんですね
黙っているとしゃべりたくなる
しゃべると黙りたくなるとか
いろいろ常に常に変わります
サンカーラ自体も変化しますね
だから無常でしょうと
最後に5番目に出てくるのはヴィンヤーナ
識ですね 心ですね 心っていうのは認識することなんですね
認識すること自体が 家だと認識する
花だと認識する  2つの認識でしょうに
同じ認識じゃないでしょうに
同じ認識だったら どこ見たっても同じものしか認識できないんです
家を見ても花を見るお花を見ても花は見える
牛を見ても花は見えることになっちゃうんです
花だと認識したならば
それは永遠だったら何見ても花と
そうはないでしょうに
だから認識っていうのは
見るものに限っても 瞬間瞬間
多数に無数にある 聞くということしても同じでしょうに
聞く認識も あいつは一つ一つ別なものを聞いてるでしょうに
だからそれは認識も見る見るうちに変わる
ものすごい多数無数にある
それは真が実体私というふうには言えないと
無常だから そうやってこんな難しいことじゃない
お釈迦様質問して答えるの比丘たちだから
じゃあ認識に聞きます
それに聞きますと 認識は永遠なものですか？瞬間瞬間変わるものですか？って言ったら
比丘たちが認識は瞬間瞬間変わるものです
それで瞬間瞬間変わるものは
苦で幸福で認めるべきか
無意味として認めるべきか
やっぱり無意味として認めるべきですよ
何か無意味であるならば
無常であるならば それが私
私の我と言うべきかと
それは言うべきじゃないんだと
それで 5つは分けているんです
その 5つの分け方も これはお釈迦様にしかできないものなんですよ
色受想行識に分けることは
今我々はもう覚えているんだから
単純に思っちゃうんだけど
これは今も誰にもできたわけじゃないんです
過去にも誰にもできたことじゃなかったし
お釈迦様後からみんないろんなことを研究しているでしょうね
体のことやらね 精神の研究
トランスパーソナルであろうか
またもう一つ心理学のありますね
なんとかサイコロジーというね
すごい超越したサイコロジーでいろいろやってるでしょうに
みんなもう原子レベルで我論でもがいてるだけでね
この体そのものを 5つに分けたい
分けられたこと 分けたことではなくて
これ大変なもう知恵なんです
それ以外何もないんだから
この体の中 物体もあって
感覚があって それから分別するという機能が能力があって
それ全て変化するものであって
それから衝動というものがあって
それから認識する ガチャガチャガチャガチャいろんなもの
それは全部セットで一緒に行動する
だから衝動がなければ認識しないでしょ
見たいという気持ちなら見ませんだからね
一緒なんです そこで花だと見ても
分別能力なきゃ花だとわからないでしょうに
だからサンカーラもヴィンヤーナも
次はウェーダナーも全部一緒に行動しているんです
離れません 離れないものがこうやってちゃんと分けて見せて
すごいわかりやすく分けてくれて
一つずつ研究してみてください
見たら無常ですよと 五種類のもので構成されている体
自分 それで一つ一つ変化する
だったらなんで自分というものを変化するんだと認めないんですかね
どちらでも消えていくものだから
こちらで自我が成り立たないんだと
だからすべてはドゥッカだよという結論にとても簡単に出ていく
それでドゥッカだよという言葉だけ
またみんな持ち運ぶでしょう
仏教は一切は空だと教えているんだと
どうだい 私の仏教の智慧という風に
あれはディッティッターナなんです
邪見なんです 持ち運べないんです
仏教の教えにしたってのは
一切皆空とか言っちゃうと私は腹が立つんですよ
軽々く言うなよと 一切皆空とかね
軽々く言うもんじゃないんですよ
それはものすごい厳密に智慧でもって分析して
きちんとその中で至る結論であって
結論だけ持ち運んじゃうと
単なる邪見になるだけなんです
仏教の本来の姿はそういう姿なんです
後になってみんなこのことわざ持ってきて
三法印でしたっけ？四法印でしたっけ
なんとか作って ね 一切皆空
涅槃寂静ではありますけどね
だから仏教を勉強する学生としてね
お寺に入って出家して一生懸命勉強する場合は
そういうそういう表現を全部頭に叩いてもらって
それはなんで なんで なんでそうなるんでしょうか
それもかなりもう何十年もかけて勉強するもので
これを暗記するために
そうやって短い短い短いことわざっていうのをいっぱいやります
ことわざみたいなものっていうのは
でも だからってそれでもって哲学を語ると言っちゃうと
結局邪見に陥りしまっちゃいますね
だから仏教は実践論である
悟るための道であって
それはもう絶対もう変わらないんですね
だから順番でお釈迦様がおっしゃっているように
色のことを研究して 常のこと
それから三帰依の業のことをまず全部それ一つ一つ見て
無常だの苦だの変わる変わるんだとかね
稲妻のように 泡のようにジリジリジリジリジリと全部変わっていくんだっていうことは経験していると
やっぱりすべては無常であって
何も執着するところはあらすということには心が変わるんですね
そこで執着しないということに心がなるんです
それが悟りという実践論なんですね
実践論を抜けちゃうと
他の世の中にあるもう一つの哲学と同じ
小さくなるんです 一応それで終わってしまって
その五蘊の説明で全て無常であるという結論に就きます
でもこの結論は出しませんよ
読んでみてください すべては故に無常であると出てきますかと
ものすごい計算してますよ
お釈迦様は 色受想行識はもうもうことごとく無常だと言ってるんだけど
故に一切は無常であるというこの格言は言いません
格言は控えておくんです
そこはお釈迦様の智慧の一つのポイントなんです
それでは私はこの句で無いと言ったんだけど
やっぱりあるんです 次に 138ページの一番最後に出てくるんですね
タスマーティヒャビッキャウェ
ですから比丘たちよ ヤンキッチルーパンアティーターナーガタパッチュッパンナン
色の中で過去の色 現在の色
将来の色というどんな色でも
過去現在未来にわたるどんな色でも
すべての色はそれからアッジャッタンバヒッダ
自分の体の中にある色
体から外にある一切の色
すべて それからオーラーリカンワスークマンワ
オーラーリカンというのは我々に掴めるはっきりした色
スークマンというのは微妙に小さく
もう掴みにくいぐらいの小さな物質
ヒーナンワパニッタンワ
優れているもの 卑しいとか言える物質的なもの
ヤンドーレーサンティケ
側にあるもの 遠くあるもの
何でもいいやと サッバンルーパン
一切の物質はネッタンマム
私のものではありませんと
それでサッバン 一切ということは我に使うんですよ
それもすごい考えてほしいところなんですね
サッバンネッタンマム
一切というと 我にあらすという場合
一切使うんです その時はもう絶対的なこと
それぐらいお釈迦様がを否定しているんです
苦の場合は一切苦であるとは言わない
これが苦である これが苦であるというのに
無我になると一切が無我であると
だからそれは我に使うために置いておいたんです
一切の色は苦であると言っても
別に言葉上問題はないんです
すべての色は今説明しましたから
時間で過去現在未来でしょ
それから空間で 空間でというのはドゥーレーサンティケ
遠くあるものを今にあることというのを空間論ですよ
それから次元論でオーラーリカン スークマン
オーラーリカンというのはいろいろな研究対象になる色
スークマンというのは素粒子みたいにどうにもつかめられないほどのものなんです
それは次元論で それからヒーナンパニッタンというのは価値観で価値論で
それからアッジャッタンバヒッダっていうのは
存在の立場から私がいるという立場から
内にある色と外にある色と
だからその言葉っていうのは
その言葉にしても すごい軽く使っているわけじゃないんです
ありとあらゆる哲学思想の立場から説明しています
存在論 いわゆる西洋型で言えばエクシステンシャリズムと言うんですね
存在論 それから時間論
空間 次元 その思想 哲学
思想 立場から見いだせる色すべて物質的なものが無常です
全部 どちらにしたっても我やと認めてはいけませんと
サッバンルーパン 一切の色は無常で無我であると
私のものではありませんと
ヤターブータン ありのまま見なさい
サッマッパンニャーヤ
正しい智慧で見るべきですよと
ありのままだから別に苦労しなくてもいいんです
余計な工夫 余計な眼鏡かけたり
丸く見える眼鏡やらカメラにつけるいろいろフィルターあるでしょうに
同じ人の写真でもいろんな方向で同じ人が 4人5人出るようにとかね
そんな風に苦労して苦労してフィルターかける必要ないんだと
そのまま見てみなさいと
すべてのルーパは智慧で見なさいよと
そこでサンカーラもウェーダナーもすべて色も認識もそういうふうに我にあらすと
だからサッバンという言葉を使うのは無我ということを言いたい時なんですね
そこまで無我は否定しているんですけど
仏教は ブッダは無我は言ったんだけど
非我は言ってないんではないかとか
またもう私の説にまで来るんだから
まあそれもその人に怒ったって意味がないんですけど
学者の方々さえもね やっぱりもう全く絶対的に我は否定するんではないんだよとね
無我と非我の間は違いもありますよとかね
だから私はお釈迦様はこの漢文で喋ったんですから
日本人には無と非の差が見えますけど
漢文では無と非の差がないんですけど
日本人にとっては無っていうのは存在なんですね
なんか分からないんですけどね
だからこれは単なる中国の文法で
この非という漢字使うのは動詞につけるんですよ
無っていうのは名詞につけるんですよ
だから単純ですよ 頭が悪い方がいいなと私は常に思いますよ
だから私は頭が悪いんだから
漢文も全然勉強してもないし
でもすぐわかるんです
やっぱり非は動詞の方につけるんだと
場合はだいたい別に動詞と名詞のそんな区別は中国語でないんだけど
なんとなく なんとなくつけるんですね
これ なんとなく作ると
調べてみると やっぱりもうそれは固定して決まっているんですね
それで あの どうしますかね
早くやりましょう  139 ページの 2番目の段落
エヴァンパッサンビッカレイスタワリア沢子ルーパスミンニッビンレティ
そのようにスタワアリア沢子頭の良い弟子たちはね
スタワというのは頭良い勉強している知識のあるという
スタっていうのは聞いたことがある
よく聞いた人って意味なんで
いわゆるよく勉強している人なんですね
頭の良いよく勉強しているアリエサワコ弟子はルーパスミンニッビンレティ
ルーパについては諦める
とにかく解放される それしか成り立たないんです
誰が何からって 2つ成り立たない
私が何々から解放されましたという風と
また実体論で ここのレベルになってくると
ただ解放されることしか言えないんです
心というものは色だから
色そのものは無常だから
だから無常たる色心でしょ
無常たる心が解放されると言ったっても
心は無常だから 何から解放されるんですかね
心もイナズマのように泡の如く無常なものでしょう
心が何からも解放する必要ないんです
それは無常のゴミだから
心さえも だからただ解放されると言った時
その動詞だけ成り立つんです
ウィラッチャキ ウィムッチャキ
でも三念処単相では言ってますけどね
ウィムッタスミン 解放されたところで
あ 解放しちゃったんだという実感も智慧も生まれる
終わったと 解放せまったと
それははっきりわかります
今までこの自分という存在があると勘違いして
山火事のようにもう私はだいたいもう火山のようにと言いたいんですけど
もう火山のようにすっごく凶暴で燃えて恐ろしい状態にいたことが
これはじーっと静かになりますから
これは分かりますよ それでキーナジャティ
もうショーが終わった
グシタンブラフマチャリア
修行も終わりました 修行を終えたと
カタンカラニーヤ なすべきことはなし終えたと
ナーパラムいったった
今これからやることはない
パジャナ よく知る それでこれからやることないなと俗世間で言ってみてください
えらいつまらない言葉でしょうね
何もやることないんだと
でも仏教の世界では これは最高な言葉なんです
だから持ち運んではいけないのです
言葉は だからもう火山が爆発して
もう轟々ともう溶岩が出て出てどうにもならない状態でいて
これはなんとか抑えてほしい
抑えてほしいと 無理だとお手上げやと思っていたところで
もう誰火は全部この全く全部静かにすることができたと
もう熱も何もなく もうもうもう石に戻ってしまったと
それでほっとするで あのほっとした瞬間のことを言ってるんですね
終わったと アヤンウッチティビッケレビク
ウッキタパリゴーイティピ
そのような状態になったビクにウッキタパリゴー
ウッキタパリゴー 私の訳は邪魔を壊したという
いろいろやる でもいろんなものは邪魔で邪魔で邪魔で
もうどうにもならない状態で
全てのもう邪魔をもう全部潰してしまったという
パリガっていうのは障壁だからね
障害 障害いろいろあって
もうもう全部潰しましたと
それからサンキンナパリコ
パリコっていうのはこの
いろんなもので我々はこの囲まれてというか
この覆われてあって自由がない
これすごい立派な言葉なんで
例えば刑務所なんかに入れた人は部屋で囲まれてそこを出られないんだけど
我々もいろんなものにもう刑務所にいるんですよ
囚人なんですよ 例えば弁護士さんやら有名な人に
あんたは法教勉強したらどうですかと
そんな変な宗教は嫌ですよと言うでしょうね
だから彼 自分の知識が自分に邪魔しているんですね
時々人々言うでしょ 私の話を聞いてすごく悩んで
私は実はずっとカトリック教の洗礼も受けているんですけど
やっぱり邪魔してるんですね
そう言われると 私 やっぱりこの人にはすごい足かせがついているんだと
だからこちらもいい加減だから
あんまり責任取りませんだからね
もう言うのは いえ それで結構ですよ
自分の宗教を信仰してくださいと
やめる必要ないんだと
だから論理的に元々ないんだから
もしその一言葉私に言うこと自体がおかしいんですよ
私の話を聞いて 本当は論理的に分かってるんでしょ
心の中で これが事実やと
なのにも関わらず 屁理屈で
本当は洗礼まで受けてるんだよという世俗的な見栄で
これ教会で洗礼ではなくて
このもう 3時間ぐらい水の中におもりでもつけて入れてあったって
どうったことないでしょうに
ただ そんなに威張ることじゃないでしょうに
ゴミやと分かったら捨てるぐらいのね
だからそういうふうに我々は師匠に足を引っ張られる
年に足を引っ張られるとかね
それで若いまあ若いんだからとかね
今年だからとかね いろんなことで
もう人間っていうのはいつでも刑務所にいるんですね
今家があるんだからとかね
食事作らなくちゃアカンだとかね
もうもうちゃんと食事作らなくちゃ
一生やってること それで
だから比丘は勉強しないとかね
修行はしないとかね そんなことを理屈でしょうかね
欲も堂々と言うところがね
だから私に言うんだからね
私はニコッとしているんだけどね
私の頭の中にどんな理屈回転してるかって覚えている
知ってるんだったらもう言わないと思いますけど
そんなもので やっぱり私たちっていうのは
いろんなことで障壁 障壁あるんですね
だから一切の障壁から解放されたっていう檻がありましてね
この檻の中にいなくちゃいけないんだ
例えば禅のお坊さんだったら
その禅をやっていたんだからって禅の檻の中に入っちゃって
やっぱりブッダにはブッダは結構ですよと
だからそんなこと言いますかね
ブッダは結構ですよと
私たちは出師方を尊敬しているんだと
でも本心はもう追い出すんだよということになるんですけどね
だから自分たちが屁理屈言ってるんだということに気づかない
なぜならというと この檻の中にいるんだからなんですね
檻の外は見えないんですね
だからかわいそうでしょうし
弱いんだったら何も言う必要もないし
どうぞ頑張ってくださいというふうにね
ですから この檻を破った人と言うんですね
障害を破った人 檻を破った人と
アブーレシコ 柱を引き抜いた者
それも普通の意味で分かりますね
私たちは何か柱に縛っておいたとすると
鎖が長いんだったらその分はぐるぐる回れます
同じところに 柱を抜いちゃったらどこでも行ける
まあそれは私たちのインドやらインドはどうか分かりませんだけど
自分の国だったらすごい分かりやすい例なんですよ
時々人々みんな牛 みんなではなくて
もう飼ってますけど 日本みたいに商売に飼ってるわけじゃないんです
牛 1頭 2頭とか ただペットみたいな感じで仕事もさせますけど
可愛がって飼ってるんですね
それで餌も買ってあげるということもしません
そこどこかに連れて行って
そこで柱一つ植えて そこに縛ってロープでもうそこら辺の葉っぱ食べさせちゃうんですね
でも他の人々もいろんなものを野菜やら作ってるのが
それ食べちゃったら困るんでしょうに
だから適当なところ見て長さ考えて縛っておくんです
でも時々牛が先へ先へ先へ食べよう食べようと首を伸ばす
その人の首がね 杭がどんどんこうちょっともう倒れちゃう
倒れたところで牛が何のことなくあっちこっち行って
人の野菜やら何でも食っちゃうんですよ
で そこで牛もやっと自由になったんだから
なかなか捕めません 走るんです
こちらから追っかけていかなくちゃいけないんですね
追っかけに行っても走る
走って走ってね けど やっと自由になったんだから捕まえたまるかと
そこで捕まっても牛の方が力強いんだから
もう何かに木なんかに牛ロープをこうやって巻いて捕まらない限りは
人間の手では止まることできません
だからそういうものはやっぱりよく子供の頃見たんだからね
ですから不意を抜いた人ということになるんですね
邪見ですね 邪見に引っかかっていたんだからね
もう杭は抜いたと イダ・ビッケービックーノ・アヴィッジャ・パヒーノ・ホーティ
それで初めてアヴィッジャっていうような無明というものは消えちゃうんだと
だから我があるんだあるんだというこの錯覚が無明なんですね
我があるわけじゃない
見出せないんだというところに来たら
見出せないことになったならば
もう無明は消えたことになるんですね
ウッチンナ・ムーラ もう根元から
根元からももう抜いたことになります
もうまた戻ることは不可能なんです
研究して結論出しちゃったんだからね
ターラー・ワットゥカタ
このターラ木の例え ターラっていうのはこのヤシ科の植物ですから
一つしかないんです 枝はないんだからね
上も取っちゃうともう出てこない
それで死んじゃうんですね
アナ・バーヴァ・カタ
もう二度と生まれないようにしたんだと
アーヤティン・アヌッパード・ダンマ
同じこと 二度と生まれなくなくなっちゃった
いわゆる一旦悟ったらもう終わり
もう消えた もう煩悩なくなった
もうそれで終了という
また堕落することっていうのはないんだと
そこら辺でもこの初期大乗仏教では思ったんですね
阿羅漢になってもまた堕落するんだと
だから自分たちはブッダになるんだと
というふうに言っただけで
修行は否定しましたからね
一人もなったわけはないんですけど
やっぱりそれはこの仏典はブッダの教えが知らないんだから
そうやって考えたことではないかなと思います
これはもう堕落するはずがないということをはっきりしているんです
エーワンコー・ビッケー・ウッキッタ・パリゴーホーティ
それはウッキッタ・パリゴー
障壁を破ったということの説明みたいだ
アヴィッジャがなくなったことが
パタンチャ・ビッケーウェ・ビックー・サンキッナ・パリッコーホーティ
檻がなくなったということはどういうことかと
イダ・ビッケーウェ・ビックーノ・ポーノ・バウィコー・ジャーティ・サンサーラ・パヒーノ・ホーティ
ウッチンヌムーロターラワットカと
ポーノーバビコ まあ再生する
死んでも生まれ変われる
この衝動があるんです
何かやりたいんだから
いつでもそれやるんですよ
やりたい 何かしたい 何かしたいって
この衝動が消えません
いつでももう続くんですね
消えませんと言ったって変な言葉なんですけど
消えますけど 消えては現れる
消えては現れるんだから
一つ消えて次の衝動が
一つの衝動消えて次の衝動が現れる
だから死ぬということが出てくる瞬間で
やっぱり生まれるという衝動が生まれる
もうどうにもならん そのまた再び生まれるというジャーティサンサール
生まれるという この輪廻ですね
その衝動がパヒーナ 消えてしまったと
ターラワットカたもうもうまたアーヤティムアヌッパダーまた二度と生まれないように
あの衝動も存在欲というか
生きて生き続けたいというあの欲も消えてしまうんだと
それで三番目の言葉はアッブーレーシコ
杭は抜いた状態って何なのかと
イダビッケービッケーもタンナーパヒーナーホーティウッチインヌムーロ
渇愛が消えてしまう だからすべては無我であると分かった瞬間で無明も消える
輪廻転生したがる衝動も消える
サンカーラも消える それから渇愛も消える
渇愛消えたことにお釈迦様が杭は抜いたという例え
障壁消えたということは無明がなくなったこと
檻がなくなったということは
輪廻転生する衝動が消えたということ
また言葉があります ニラッガラ
ニラッガラっていうのは鍵が開けたって意味なんですね
そこ あの すごいたくさんありますけど
経典はもうそこで終わりましたけどね
まだたくさんあります
それを一つ一つ説明しようと
で あの また まあここら辺ね
ニラッガラ ニラッガラっていうのは
やっぱりこのここ 自我ということで鍵かけてますから
自我がなくなっちゃえば何かオープンになっちゃうんですね
例えば風船の例えば風船が割れちゃったらもう何もなくなくなっちゃいますような感じで
鍵の状態なんですね それで我々心の中で鍵かけてる状態があるんですね
それは消えてしまうと
鍵が開けた状態っていうのはオーランバーゲーサンヨージャナという存在に対する欲なんですね
それは五つあります それは消えるんだと
カタンチャビクービクーアリーヨーパンナダジョー
パンナバーロヴィサンユット
旗を下ろして重荷を下ろし
縛りを解いている それまあただもうそれを文学的に
このいかに解脱したことがすごいかということを言ってるんですね
だから旗を下ろしたということは
もう戦争に行って戦って戦って
もうもう終わったんだから
もう旗を下ろしちゃうんですね
もう旗を下ろしましょうと
もう用がないと それで重荷もなくなったと
もう解いたと もう縛りはねという状態
イダビッケービッケーのアスミマーナパヒーノーホーティ
ある比丘にアスミマーナ
このアスミマーナという言葉もよくそのまま覚えてください
で これもなかなか大変な
アスミっていうのは日本語になりませんね
ドイツ語でザインという動詞がありますね
英語ではBE動詞なんですね BE
動詞ですけどね BEはもともとかもしれませんだけど
だからドイツ語でイッシュビンと言うんだから
英語だったらアイアムでしょ
で BE動詞 アスミっていうのはこのBE動詞なんです BE
動詞自分に入れると私
アイアムという意味なんですね
だからアイアムと言ったって
もう英語で言ったって意味がないんですよ
まあドイツ語哲学っぽいだからね
ダズザインといえばね
よろしいんですけど その時は名詞になっちゃいますけどね
アスミマーナ 私がいる
アスミっていうのは マーナっていうのはその感覚のこと
マーナはマンでしょ？だから比べることでしょ
だから自分尺度があって
その尺度でもって他を比べるんですね
私がいると思ったら 私がいるという尺度で他もいるということになっちゃうんですね
だから私いるんだ 存在しているんだって
その実感 それが消えちゃったんだと
だからこのデカルトが言っていることをね
コビトはエルゴスムということなんですね
therefore私がいるんだと
I think therefore I am
だから彼らがこのアイアムということを私がいるんだということをとにかく証明してやろうではないかと
自我をあるんだと証明してみせますよと
で かなり無理やってますね
ないんだから 元々 だからそれで今までやってますよ
その哲学は ここでお釈迦様は言ったのは
このEgosumという言葉は消えるんだと
アスママナ 私が思う ゆえに私がいる
私がいるというこのマンが消えますね
消えるんだだから その人に旗降りた人やと言うんだと
旗を下ろした人 重荷を置いた人
それから縛りを解いた人と言うんだよと
エワン・ヴィムッタチッタン・コー・ビクケ・ビッ
くん・サインダ・デーヴァーサ・ブラフマーサ・パジャーパティカー・アンナ・セーサン・ナーディ・ガッチャティ・イダン・ニッシタン・タターガタサ・ヴィンヤーナンティ
このようにヴィムッタチッタン
心が解脱 解脱した心っていうのは瞬間の心なんですけど
神々であろうが ブラフマンであろうか
パジャーパティであろうか
もうこれはこのブラフマだけ設定する以前
インドではこの絶対神はブラフマとも言うし
パジャーパティとも言うんですね
もともとはパジャーパティと言っていたんですけども
ページであって もうもうもうやりましょう
時間もなくなっちゃった
難しい 今日終わると思ったんですけど
いや このくらいでやめます
できることならもう覚えておいてください
この で また繰り返しちゃうと
もうもうもう切りがなくなっちゃいますからね
いっぺんにやった方が私にとっては楽でしたけど
[笑い]